of the BBC Richard Sharp has announced
his resignation Britain's public
broadcaster having to report that its
chairman has to quit over his dealings
with a former prime minister I feel that
this matter May well be a distraction
from the corporation's good work were I
to remain in post until the end of my
term in 2020 Richard Sharp helped to
arrange a million dollar personal loan
application for Boris Johnson who was
prime minister at the time
Johnson who doesn't want to talk about
it now later recommended that sharp
should be appointed into the
non-executive role in which he was to
oversee the quality and impartiality in
the EBC output this does call into
question the impartiality of Britain's
public broadcaster at a high level not
only that it's the timeline that's
worrying so many people two years before
anything was found out and the staff
here didn't know anything until they
read about it in the newspaper labor
Britain's main opposition party says
sharp should have already been sacked
for his actions it's clear that he
failed to act appropriately in this
process and it's right that he resigned
but he should have been sacked by the
Prime Minister weeks ago because this
whole murky Affair and his cozy
relationship with the Prime Minister and
and Rishi sunak himself has brought
Untold reputational damage to the BBC
prime minister Rishi sunak is now Under
Pressure to abandon political
appointments at the BC but he doesn't
want to talk about it there's an
established appointments process for all
these things and it will be right that
we turn to that when the time is right
and so the BBC has taken a blow to its
integrity and the government once again
stands accused of cronyism
Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera London